One more topic before we finish
up with drawing, and that's text.
Text is actually a super
complicated topic.
So we're just going to do
the minimum necessary to
get some text on the screen.
First thing, text in LibGDX
is actually made of bitmaps.
That means instead of describing
the shape of the characters,
we describe the actual pixels
that make up the text.
We'll discuss bitmaps and
textures in more detail later on, but
the short version is just that we use a
SpriteBatch instead of a shape renderer.
Everything else is almost identical.
So in this demo,
we'll create our SpriteBatch and
we'll use just the default bitmap font.
Then we'll set the scale so
the font appears a little bit bigger and
then we need to set the filter.
Now texture filtering is
a complicated topic all on it's own.
We'll talk more about that later.
But it's how we determine what a bitmap
looks like when the bitmap gets drawn at
a larger size than it was
originally designed to be drawn at.
This linear filter makes sure that the
text doesn't look all pixellated when we
draw it large.
Sprite batches and fonts need to be
disposed of, just like a ShapeRenderer.
Finally down in renderer,
we clear the screen just like normal.
We begin a batch of the sprite batch
just like with a shape renderer
except there's no mode.
Then to actually draw, we call draw on
the font object passing in the batch,
the text we want to draw and
the position.
Also remember to end
your sprite batches.
And there we go,
we've got Text on the screen.